arriving at court for a third day of
cross-examination Lucy letby continued
to face questions about whether she
murdered seven babies and tried to kill
10 others during Friday morning session
the nurse who worked in the neonatal
unit at the Countess of Chester Hospital
denied taking any enjoyment from seeing
babies in distress she dismissed claims
she'd falsified Hospital paperwork as an
alibi and told a jury that Mistakes by
her colleagues led to the death of one
of her alleged victims
the court was shown a series of text
messages exchanged between Lucy leppy
and a colleague following the death of
child d
in one message her colleague said just
think carefully about whether you should
be working if you feel so bad maybe you
need to take time off Miss letby replied
work is always my priority I won't let
it affect it I just haven't let myself
cry over it until now once I've let it
out tonight my head will be clearer
her colleague then raised concerns about
some of the previous deaths yeah there
is something odd about that night and
the other three that went so suddenly
let me questioned what do you mean odd
that we lost three and in different
circumstances
I don't know were they that different
her colleague replied ignore me I'm
speculating
it was between June 2015 and June 2016
when an unusual spike in baby deaths
were recorded at the Countess of Chester
Hospital
in July 2016 Miss letby was removed from
Frontline duties after concerns were
raised she was charged in November 2020.
this has been an emotional and testing
week for Lucy letby twice she's cried
whilst giving evidence a temperament in
the spotlight as she's being
cross-examined on several occasions
she's been asked whether she's lying
about her recollection of events or if
she's making up evidence as she goes
along and if she injected air into some
of the babies she allegedly murdered
Lucy let beep is now eight months into
her murder trial in which she's adamant
she didn't kill or tried to kill anyone
she'll return to the Crown Court to
answer more questions next week into man
Rasheed Sky News Manchester